in July 2022 if you bought something
from the online clothing giant Xi'an you
might have spotted something startling
on the clothing tag do not drag queen
due to water saving technology need your
help washing with the soft detergent the
first time wait what need your help you
do a double take and realize that yes
that is definitely a sweatshop worker in
China crying out for help and then you
discover you're not alone tons of people
have been finding these scary messages
for help on the labels of their Xi'an
clothes and people were freaking out it
turns out the low prices might be too
good to be true after all but then just
as people started to really Panic the
entire story gets debunked as a hoax it
shows a woman from Michigan in the
United States that found this helped me
sign in a package from an underwear
company located in the Philippines and
now Matthew although we're still not
sure whether this helped me sign was a
real cry for help or not it is certainly
not related to Sheen the Chinese
clothing company accused of forced labor
in the video everyone briefs a sigh of
relief now that everyone can go back to
shopping on Xi'an with a clear
conscience but even though the story was
a hoax the sad part is that it's
probably not far from the truth this
little hoax is a parody of the bigger
problem of fast fashion fast fashion is
basically Peak hyper consumerism with an
average piece of clothes in America is
worn just seven times before being
thrown out while Americans buy an
average of 68 items of clothing every
single year and all of this means one
thing money a lot of money
we're making money money money money
money money but to make this fast
fashion machine operate you need some
ruthless heartless business practices
and at the top of it all is she in the
most powerful secretive fashion company
in the world that is bigger than Amazon
my name is Jake Tran I make
documentaries on money power war and
crime in my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
you just have to be following me at Jake
Tren and you're automatically entered a
few of you have won already watch out
for fake accounts I will never message
you asking for money and this is
secretive Ultra profitable and Ultra
Fast Business of Xi'an
[Music]
if you're interested in starting your
own fast fashion company or whatever
other business then you gotta check out
one of the audiobooks that completely
changed my life the war of art by
Stephen pressfield in a pressfield
phrase the pursuit of any creative
Endeavor as a war that you have to fight
to finale with it's insanely
inspirational and this audiobook is only
two and a half hours long and the best
part is that you can listen to this
audiobook for free right now by signing
up for audible so you have no excuse to
not check this out audible is a super
easy sell for me because I've been using
them for over four years now and the
stuff I've learned from their audiobooks
has completely changed my life for the
better and I cannot thank them enough I
would rarely be using audible to the day
I die because listening to audiobooks is
way easier than reading and you can do
it anywhere I listen when I'm driving
working out and doing chores audible is
the biggest audiobook platform in the
world that is constantly getting bigger
and it has audiobooks on anything you
could possibly be interested in books on
how to make money famous Memoirs
everything once you sign up you can
choose one title per month to keep from
their entire catalog and that includes
new releases and bestsellers you'll also
have access to exclusive audible
originals from a clean experts and top
celebrities and you can try it out
before fully committing because new
members get 30 days of audible for free
so pause the video and get 30 days of
audible for free by going to audible.com
or texting jaytren to 500 500 again
that's audible.com with the link below
or text Jay trenth of 500 500 thanks to
Audible for sponsoring this video
[Music]
thank you
Sheehan seemed to blow up overnight what
was once an unknown company suddenly
started popping up all over Instagram
and Tick Tock it was even being promoted
by huge influencers and celebrities like
Lil Nas X and Katy Perry in a few short
months the Xi'an Instagram account had
over 25 million followers and before you
knew it you couldn't go a day without
seeing a video of someone unpacking a
massive bag of clothes and happily
captioning it Sheehan Hall each one of
those videos attracted millions of
viewers who were quickly converted into
devoted Xi'an customers all in less than
a minute
how how had this no name no clout
company just appeared out of nowhere and
taken over online shopping well to find
out you'll have to go right back to the
start of Sheen
back when its creator Yang Tien Chris
Shu started a Drop Shipping business
called she inside but here's the thing
looking into Chris's shoes past is kinda
problematic he's pretty much The
Stereotype of a mysterious
behind-the-scenes CEO he's so elusive
that you can only find a few photos of
him on the internet but here's what we
do know according to a local Chinese
media report young tianshu was born in
1984 in the shangdong province of China
even though his parents were poor
Farmers they placed huge importance on
education yangtan wanted to live up to
his family's expectations so he worked
hard in high school and eventually went
off to college at qingdao University of
Science and Technology there he split
his time between studying and working
part-time before finally Landing a job
where he was in charge of search engine
optimization SEO for a company SEO is
sort of like a hack businesses and
websites use to rank higher in Google
search results if your website has great
SEO it will probably be somewhere on the
first page of search results so when you
search best places to eat in New York
City the websites that use the best SEO
practices will be the first thing you
see in a nutshell Shu was in charge of
making sure the company's website was
being found by people on the internet
even people who weren't really looking
for them the job made him an expert on
SEO and getting people to click on and
visit websites a skill that would come
in handy just a few years later when he
finally struck out on his own
2008 Hugh quit his job to help create a
new company called Nanjing dienwe
Information Technology at first they
were in the market for anything that
could be made cheaply in China and sold
overseas cell phones kitchen supplies
pens sunglasses anything but in 2009 it
all changed
young tian's fiance had been desperately
searching for a wedding dress when he
saw how big a deal it was to find a gown
for their special day he had an idea
switching a business's Focus to women's
apparel the ball got rolling pretty fast
she'd changed the company's name to she
inside to reflect their new niche in
2011 and by 2015 they dropped the side
and adopted the short and sweet moniker
of Sheen that it goes by today
Hugh wanted the name to be easier for
Searchers to spell and remember and way
more attractive to search engines it was
right around this time that the company
really started making a name for itself
but that wasn't enough
she wanted to take Sheehan Global but to
do that he would have to compete with
established fast fashion brands like h m
and Zara if she and was going to stand
out and take over the fast fashion
industry it was going to have to
formulate a new business model that
would leave its competitors in the dust
foreign
[Music]
was very different from its fast fashion
competitors Chris Shea didn't care about
the art of fashion or designing Timeless
clothes or having a million in person
stores worldwide all he cared about was
ruthless hyper efficiency he is the
modern day Henry Ford but for fashion
all business no art no emotions luckily
his years as an SEO expert meant he knew
exactly how to get she into the top of
Google search results for cheap clothes
and with that skill Shia kick-started
the company's International success
starting with Sheehan's trademark 100
online on-demand business model at first
Sheen wasn't even designing or producing
any clothes itself the company basically
worked like a massive fashion Drop
Shipping service they would advertise
clothes other designers or factories
made online and once people started
ordering the clothes she and would send
those orders on to the Third party
manufacturers pay them and have them
shipped directly to the customers who
bought them then when Sheehan finally
started manufacturing its own clothes it
also took a shortcut other fashion
retailers like Zara would spend a lot of
time and money making big batches of
clothing designs hoping they would be
popular with consumers but for Sheehan
that left too much up in the air so they
manufactured their products in small
batches tested how people responded to
them and only ramped up production for
the most popular items that way they
could sell their products for a
ridiculously low price always have new
Styles being launched and make it look
like they were environmentally friendly
for cutting down on inventory waste all
while still bringing in a huge profit
because they never had to recoup their
production costs with a strong on-demand
business model up and running the next
step was getting their name out there
Sheehan was gonna have to be everywhere
all the time for people to become
interested in buying from them enter
influencer marketing apps like Instagram
and Tick Tock breathed life into the
Xi'an brand all it took was getting a
few influencers on board making fun
little videos showing off everything
they bought from Sheehan and tagging it
hashtag Shian and hashtag Sheehan Hall
while telling their followers how they
got all those clothes for just five
hundred dollars
Sheehan Halls became so popular online
that everyone wanted to get in on the
fun and the fame y'all the scene package
that I was waiting for are Vibe so let's
open it and it's really heavy so it's
hard to explain just how much of a game
changer this was see typically if you
want influencers to promote your product
you would have to pay them a lot of
money to make a video on it for YouTube
or Tick Tock but she and was different
just the idea of a giant fashion haul
like these for just a few hundred
dollars already made a pretty good viral
video since influencers are always on
the lookout for the next viral video
idea they wanted to make videos on giant
cheap fashion Halls just for the views
and the only choice they had to go to to
make this video possible
[Music]
it was a genius self-sustaining
marketing campaign and before long
everyone under the age of 30 knew the
name Sheehan but now that Sheehan was
feeding an insatiable demand they ran
into their next challenge
if they were going to become the biggest
fastest fashion brand the world had ever
seen they were going to be more than
just publicity they were going to have
to keep up with every single Fashion
Trend in real time and to do that they
were gonna have to work faster than any
fast fashion brand had ever worked
before
the OG is a fast fashion like Zara
revolutionized the industry with their
five-week turnaround times from putting
a design on paper to it actually being
sold in stores in comparison Sheehan
could complete a design make a product
and ship it off in as little as 10 days
it was unheard of she and started
pumping out new designs and clothes at
record speeds and they did it by paying
insanely close attention to what their
customers were buying and not enough we
care so much about our customers
experience type of way but moreover we
want to get into the brains of these
buyers and know exactly what they want
before they do type of way that's how
Sheehan developed a powerful secret
algorithm for predicting what trends are
going to blow up next
Sheehan is so good at predicting Trends
and Manufacturing clothes that match
them that a member of the UK Parliament
actually said the company had a quote
data collection Network to rival many of
the world's intelligence agencies end
quote
yes a Chinese clothing retailer is
rivaling most of the world's
intelligence agencies when it comes to
data their algorithm is basically the
equivalent of the YouTube algorithm but
for clothes and all of this is done
behind closed doors
privately held Sheehan doesn't have to
disclose its financial information and
that's the final layer to their
multi-billion dollar success because if
nobody knows how much you're worth or
how exactly you're making so much money
nobody can control you and that's coming
from a company that's even bigger than
Amazon in the United States today she
and adds almost 9 000 new items to their
website every day they ship to over 150
countries and the company is valued at
over 100 billion dollars more than its
two biggest competitors h m and Zara
combined but all this success hasn't
come without a few controversies
[Music]
in 2020 the site started selling a
swastika necklace with the product
description metal swastika pendant
necklace for Just Two Dollars fifty
cents After People noticed it and called
them out she and actually doubled down
and defended the necklace one she and
representative said quote for the record
Sheehan was not selling a Nazi swastika
pendant the necklace is a Buddhist
swastika which has symbolized
spirituality and good fortune for more
than a thousand years end quote which is
in fact true the symbol has been around
long before the Germans bastardized it
regardless they ended up removing the
necklace anyway stating quote however
because we understand the two symbols
can be confused and one is highly
offensive we have removed the product
from our site end quote this wasn't the
first time that a questionable item was
sold by Xi'an only a few months earlier
they had been selling Islamic prayer
mats and labeling the items as quote
decorative rugs and quote once again she
unapologized and removed the product
from their site after public outrage but
there's more this is Vanessa Bowman who
spent over 30 years creating a name for
herself in the art world she had a nice
career Selling paintings of scenes from
around her Town one day a fan reached
out and asked if she'd been
collaborating with Sheen she immediately
said no but imagine her shock when she
found a cheap sweater for sale on the
site with one of her paintings printed
on the front the painting she had done
of her own garden the company had never
reached out to her or even tried to
change anything about her artwork to
make it look a little more original they
had literally just stolen the picture
and slapped it on a low quality sweater
and Vanessa wasn't alone in discovering
she and had ripped off her art hundreds
of artists and designers have the same
story
Sheen stole my art the company has even
gone so far as to steal the designs and
exact logos from famous clothing brands
like stucy and while giant Brands like
stucy can afford to hold Sheen
accountable most Independent Artists
don't have the resources to go
toe-to-toe with a billion dollar company
in China so usually the whole Scandal
just falls through the cracks and the
artists get nothing and for Sheen the
few lawsuits they actually do get are
basically just the cost of doing
business but that's only the tip of the
iceberg
foreign
[Music]
as to why the company is so secretive is
that their supply chain is violating a
lot of labor laws that they don't want
the world to know about long before the
help me notes people were getting loud
about the possibility of Sheen using
child labor or exploiting their workers
in 2021 an investigation into Sheen's
production factories found that their
employees were working 12 to 14 hour
days with just one day off per month and
most of them end up working well over 75
hours a week which is a clear violation
of Chinese labor laws that stipulate a
working week can only be a maximum of 40
hours overtime cannot exceed 36 hours
per month and workers must have at least
one day off per week
yes she and violates even Chinese labor
laws
besides the illegally long hours their
working conditions mirror past
conditions that have led to Sweatshop
workers burning inside a fire because
they were locked inside their sweatshop
employees work in uncomfortable cramped
rooms with barred windows and no
emergency exits many of the production
sites are just makeshift factories set
up in residential buildings and there is
little to no oversight or rules
protecting any of the workers plus
Sheehan doesn't issue them any
employment contracts so on paper they're
not even actually employed or entitled
to any labor rights they might ask for
you know who she and reminds me a lot of
Monsanto also known as the company that
owns the world's food supply just like
Sheen Monsanto has a tight grip on the
industry they control and they've done
some really awful things to climb to the
top how awful you ask well bad enough
that if we told you about it here on the
channel it would definitely get
demonetized but obviously we couldn't
keep a documentary like that from you
guys there's just too much juicy
information about Monsanto that you need
to know
so instead of posting it in public we
released it as an exclusive
feature-length private documentary that
goes into every last grimy detail about
monsanto's darkest practices
and so far it's been a huge hit with our
channel members all you have to do to
access our exclusive Monsanto
documentary and every other full-length
dock that's just too messed up or too
controversial to post publicly is click
the join button below
signing up you'll be able to watch the
Monsanto documentary and others like
every Epstein MK Ultra the bin Laden
papers the roots of Middle East Terror
and a really controversial one coming up
next a CIA black sites that we are
legitimately nervous about
it's all the stuff you should be
learning in school and University but
definitely aren't plus unlike University
you can get all of this for only five
dollars a month and there's a refund
policy too unlike most YouTube
memberships so if you join and you don't
think it's worth it email us within your
first month of joining and we will
personally refund you for your first
month after your first month there is no
refund
so pause the video right now and click
that join button below
foreign
what's up everyone hope you guys enjoyed
the video and if you are new here my
name is Jake and this is one of the
biggest channels on YouTube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime so we make multiple videos just
like this one every single week for free
and all you have to do is click that
subscribe button below and remember you
can always dislike and unsubscribe
whenever you want so you have nothing to
lose if you want shorter versions of
these videos you can follow me on
Facebook and for just a win a thousand
dollars you can follow me on Instagram
jaketran that is going to wrap it up
stay dangerous out there and I will see
you guys in the next one
[Applause]
thank you
foreign